talk about an identity crisis like i had
gone from being a character
almost as often as i was myself
miley cyrus may have had the best of
both worlds
[Applause]
but the singer is now revealing she went
through an identity crisis
after starring on disney channel's
hannah montana
i'm hannah montana on the latest episode
of spotify's rock this podcast with
alison hagendorf the 28 year old singer
opens up about how the show
which follows a normal teenager who
lives a secret double life as a pop star
skewed her sense of self the concept of
the show
is that when you're this character when
you have this alter
e ego you're valuable you've got like
millions of fans you're like
the biggest star in the world and then
the concept was that when i looked like
myself when i didn't have the wig on
anymore that no one cared about me
it wasn't a star anymore miley also
reveals that she felt without hannah
montana
no one cared about her a concept she
knew she had to break
now as you get older i've started to
grow out of that character a little bit
and it's harder to relate to her but it
doesn't mean that like you know
the show isn't still gonna go on you
know people can still watch the episodes
and whatever and i think that's
that's good the triple threat also
recalls shaking off that feeling after
her first post hannah montana album
bangers i almost created like a
characterized
version of myself at times like
i never created a character where it
wasn't me but i was aware of how people
saw me and i kind of played into it a
little bit
i came in like a
[Music]
like when i noticed that people get that
i would stick my tongue out instead of
they told me stop sticking your tongue
out i would do it more
and like when people are pissed that
means they care so that
makes you want to do it too since
bangers miley has released several
successful studio albums
miley cyrus and her dead pets younger
now and her latest album
plastic hearts which came out in
november now i feel like
plastic hearts is almost just kind of an
accumulation of everything that i've
ever been into one record
i feel like it's it's you know kind of
almost like a collage of
everything i've been
you